Ось так клином військові іноді
переганяють f-15 та f-16 на далекі
відстані але й поки що не в Україну хоча
дискусія про поставки західних літаків
вже активно ведеться Польща готова
передати Україні винищувачі f16 у
координації знаток про це заявив
польський Прем'єр Матео шмаровецький за
словами його колеги прем'єра Нідерландів
маркарюта жодних табу немає але є
критерії які не можна порушувати їх
сформулював французький президент
Еммануель макрон
Це залежить від Запитів які надходять а
не від чуток навколо ці запити ще не
сформульовані але щоразу коли ми
отримуємо їх ми дивимося що на нашу
думку може бути корисним що ми можемо
зробити і в межах якого часу другий
критерій переконатися що це не призведе
до ескалації щоб спорядження якими
відправляємо не було використано для
удару по російській території третій
критерій полягає в тому що ці поставки
не повинні розслабити здатність
французької армію захистити власну
територію та наших громадян
президент США Джо Байден сказав короткий
ні на запитання журналістів чи планують
Сполучені Штати передати Україні
винищувачі 4-го покоління при цьому ще
минулого літа конгрес схвалив
фінансування програми підготовки
українських пілотів на американських
винищувачах виділивши на це 100
мільйонів доларів
це так само як і станками під час
модернізації військово-повітряних сил у
Європі та США з'являється обладнання яке
вони потенційно можуть передати Україні
Це був би ще один крок до ескалації Але
я думаю що зараз Захід хоче подивитися
як Україна впорається з танками а потім
оцінити ситуацію тож оце питання
безумовно буде включено до порядку
денного майбутнього зустрічі у Rammstein
ми побачимо що тиск наростатиме але я не
очікував би що з цього питання будуть
ухвалені якісь рішення вже найближчим
часом
видання політико з посиланням на
Європейських військових та дипломатів
пише що обговорення перспективи
постачання винищувачів в Україні вже
розпочалося очікується Що це питання
спричинить ще більше суперечок ніж
постачання київ-бутанків за оцінками
повітряних сил України для захисту неба
потрібно до 200 багатоцільових літаків
запит на винищувачі існує вже кілька
місяців і його активно розглядають як у
Вашингтоні так і в столиціях союзників
багато хто вважає що підійшли б
американські f-16 Але чесно кажучи якщо
розглянутий можливості як задовольнити
цей запит Зеленського Мені здається
краще було б поставити Україні
радянський літак із Польщі від інших
союзників в арсеналах яких є багато
обладнання радянських часів ці літаки
добрі це літаки на яких український
пілоти літали раніше для яких в Україні
є логістика думаю що слід розглянути
такі варіанти в першу чергу і можливо
для того щоб ці літаки були відправлені
в Україну США могли б надати свої f-16
країні яка віддасть свої винищувачі
радянською розробки
багато західних країн не готові
постачати Києву наступальне озброєння Не
кажучи вже про винищувачі
раніше і щодо танків так тепер і щодо
літаків канцлер ФРН у лавшольс
висловлюється проти він окреслив червону
лінію постачати Україні бойові літаки
Німеччина не готова
та сосни хто я дуже рано дав зрозуміти
що провинищувачі не йдеться і ясно дав
зрозуміти це коли ми обговорювали
безпольотну зону над Україною Я також
сказав американському президенту що ми
не будемо цього робити і ця позиція не
змінилася І не зміниться
експерти зазначають що в питанні
винищувачів на відміну від танків ролі
Німеччини буде обмеженою адже літаки Не
сильна сторона Арсеналу ФРН
канцлер ФРН не матиме тих важелів впливу
і тієї ролі яку він грав при ухваленні
рішення про постачання танків німецького
виробництва тож насправді країна яка має
ухвалити рішення про постачання f16 це
Сполучені Штати тому я думаю що у цьому
питанні канцлер залишиться лише
спостерігачем
після довгих місяців вагання Німеччина
та США таки дали свою згоду на відправку
леопардів та абрамсів в Україну і Київ
не втрачає надію що з часом вдасться
отримати літаки та далекобійні ракети
президент України Володимир Зеленський
вже обговорив цю тему з генсеком НАТО і
єнсом столтонбергом він назвав це мрією
і Важливим завданням
також далекобійних ракет для України
важливо ми маємо розширювати і нашу
співпрацювати в артилерії ми маємо вийти
на
постачання літаків для України і це Мрія
і це задача
середа західних літаків найбільше Київ
хотів би отримати f16 це легкий
американський багатофункціональний
винищувач четвертого покоління загалом
випущено понад чотири з половиною тисячі
таких літаків цей наймасовіший винищувач
четвертого покоління які числиться на
озброєнні 24 держав світу коштує залежно
від модифікації в середньому 34 мільйони
доларів f16 здатен виконувати Практично
всі військові завдання відповідь для них
боїв до високоточного бомбардування і
підтримки наземних сил його цінують за
зручність у пілотуванні та
обслуговуванні Україна має намір з тією
ж наполегливістю добиватися цих літаків
як раніше танків